good evening if you want to attend an
nfl game in las vegas you need to be
vaccinated thanks for joining us here at
five i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis so far las vegas is the only
franchise requiring fans to be
vaccinated sports director chris
matthews joins us live with what you
need to know before you attend a raiders
game
well thank you brian yeah following the
governor's recommendation the raiders
are making it a mandatory decision now
that all fans going inside legion
stadium to watch a raiders game must be
vaccinated raiders owner mark davis
telling us just today that it was a very
difficult decision to make and he will
be certainly shutting some fans out now
those who
do not get the jab will not be allowed
inside we might mention that all fans
under 12 years old will only need to
wear a mask everybody else needs the
vaccine to go inside and watch the
raiders no other team in the nfl has
done this as you mentioned so raiders
owner mark davis is blazing a trail
during a pandemic and hoping fans make
the right decision for their own health
if people are concerned about taking the
shot or whatever that we will
refund their money for the season for
the nine games we'll give them a full
refund
or they can roll their
ticket money over until next season if
in fact they roll it over until next
season they'll get the
full 10 game season for the nine games
that they're returning
if in fact they get a refund
they will then
just pay next year the full price for
their season tickets which will be the
same prices this year's
all right now through the nfl's
collective bargaining agreement players
are exempt
from the vaccine mandate we're told the
raiders have the highest rate of
vaccinated players in the nfl we'll have
more on that side of the story coming up
in sports at six o'clock now the other
teams in las vegas making decisions the
unlv football team they will also play
inside of legion stadium but as of right
now only the mask mandate you must wear
a mask inside to watch rebel football as
for the golden knights they will
continue to monitor the situation no
changes in covet protocols for the
golden knights as of right now and of
course the other teams the aces las
vegas aces they don't have the 4 000
inside so
really known as no necessary adjustments
there for the wnba basketball team as
for the aviators the lights and nascar
all those held outside so no mask or
vaccine required for those events